le patron de ce resto est un client
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu avoir une table
à la dernière minute et c'est pour ça
qu'on aille table aussi grande on aura
peut-être droit à des suppléments avec
un peu de chance puis 55 $ pour un steak
ils sont connus pour leur viande les 35
de la poisse au mans qu'est ce qui te
fais pas ce prix d'also mauritus
[Musique]
m
seriez-vous mathieu le fils d'harold
exact et voici dany qui est également le
fils d'argent je savais même pas qu'il
avait deux fils et une fille
[Musique]
et alors ça va ça ne fera du bien de
passer du temps avec mon père ça mais
pas beaucoup arrivent et quand j'étais
petit
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fous là où à sanaa
maureen et complètement bourré leur
technique ces deux ils attendent que les
oiseaux s'envolent avec les petits
ensuite ils les mettent à frire c'est
triste je savais pas du tout comment il
faisait avant de demander je pensais pas
qu'ils prenaient aussi l'équipe qui va
bientôt faire la connaissance d'un tas
de gens formidables et passionnante
j'ai pas tenu plus d'un mois parce que
j'aimais trop les drogues
au lion de harold meilleur vite vous
êtes sur la liste de la visite publique
pour l'instant c'est la visite privée
c'est certainement une erreur des knicks
et n'importe quoi arrête
elle entend parfaitement ce que nous
disons
[Musique]
voir ça
quoique je l'avais encore jamais eu
courir ouais c'est comme ça quel coût
qu'est ce qu'ils sont
[Musique]
le rude
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as tu avais lantigua
[Musique]